hey 42 here by 1978
dickie eklund was on top of the world
a successful boxer he was the only man
alive to go the distance
with sugar ray leonard one of the
greatest fighters who ever stepped foot
in the ring
but by 1993 this would all change
as a subject of an hbo documentary
eklund led
a group of filmmakers around his home
town of laurel
showing them where he grew up and
outlining his intentions to make a
comeback into the world of boxing but
the documentary was not what he expected
it to be
called hyung crack street lost lives in
lowell
the documentary was an expose on the
crack epidemic
of the early 90s tracing its origins and
focusing
on the lives of free addicts in the
economically depressed former mill city
of lowell massachusetts
a prostitute her pimp and former boxer
dickie eklund the film documented
eklund's struggle with addiction
his attempts to reform himself for his
career and his young son
as well as his efforts to prevent his
habit from relapsing
and when he failed the crimes he
committed
to feed it it was a documentary eklund
saw for the first time
in prison after he had been arrested
although fooled by the documentary crew
the film was simply about
what was happening before the camera had
ecklund
recovered from his addiction and pursued
boxing it would have been about what he
wanted
but instead his addiction had consumed
him
and for now destroyed his life
nobody wants to ruin their life and
perhaps
you never think you will but every day
many of us make decisions that
fundamentally and
irrecoverably alter the trajectory of
our lives
sometimes for the worse whilst many
people's lives are destroyed through no
fault of their own such as health issues
or a lack of support or opportunity
others are caused by the decisions we
make
every single day decisions each of us
hold
responsibility for so here are some
interesting ways you can
totally bugger up your life that can
mostly
be avoided most of us understand that
having good finances
is important but few understand just how
destructive
being fiscally irresponsible can
actually be
and just how easily money issues can
tear your life apart
and sometimes end it all together
whilst your mind may immediately jump to
the most extreme financial issues such
as bankruptcy and homelessness
there are more subtle but insidious ways
that poor financial planning
can utterly destroy your life and you're
probably
doing at least one of them already
scientists have spent years studying the
many health risks
that come with poor finances and because
in america at least 62 percent of
people's mental and physical health
is directly affected by financial stress
these risks have to be taken seriously
financial stresses aren't just
psychological they also
physically hurt and even damage the body
possibly even fatally migraines
insomnia increased levels of physical
pain
inability to go to work which further
increases stress
and cardiovascular disease are all
strongly linked to having financial
stresses
cardiovascular disease at 23.5 percent
is the world health organization's
leading cause of death globally
generally speaking it's not a good idea
to increase
the likelihood of your most likely cause
of death but
you could be doing exactly that with
your finances right now
and you might not even realize it but
even worse than this
financial stresses have been
demonstrated to have a clear negative
effect
on mental health triggering destructive
conditions like depression
hopelessness and other mood disorders
perhaps even more concerning
is that financial stresses drive at
least one-third of us
to seek out unhealthy ways of coping
such as
overeating drinking or perhaps worst of
all
compulsive spending that's right sadly
many people spend to deal with their
anxiety
over their spending issues these only
exacerbate
your financial problems and further
degrade your mental health trapping you
in a painful
toxic spiral interestingly
financial stress also affects your
ability
to problem solve so before you think
well i'll just put myself up by the
bootstraps think again
a study published in science
demonstrated that people struggling with
poverty
found it far harder to engage with
abstract thinking and cognitive
control when faced with expensive bills
the mere sight of something they would
struggle to afford was enough to
significantly impact their ability
to problem solve the irony of this is
what makes
financial hardship such a vindictive
destroyer
of lives but how does this
subtle yet destructive financial stress
come about
obviously debt is the largest cause of
financial stress but
often debt can be so sneaky you don't
know it's happening to you
until it's too late 80.9 of american
baby boomers
are in debt as are 79.9
of gen x's and the average uk household
debt stands at 15
400 pounds these are typically credit
card debts
medical debts student loans personal
loans
overdraft charges payday loans and
overdue
phone and utility bills in other words
money borrowed to pay for something that
could not otherwise be afforded
whilst this in itself may seem like a
harmless choice at the time
such as taking out an expensive phone
contract for the new iphone
the way debt is structured can cause
lasting
and debilitating effects on one's life
not only are you paying a whole chunk
more overall for the item than you would
if you purchased it outright with cash
but if you fail to pay back the loan or
don't make payments on time
then you will usually be hit with a
higher interest rate every
year until the debt is paid off which
compounds the debt
further increasing your liability this
is made even worse when you consider
that roughly 22 percent of people
default on loans and end up taking out
another loan to pay it off which adds
multiple levels of compound interest
because you're essentially paying
interest on a new loan
to pay off interest on an old loan plus
the amount borrowed of course this only
compounds stress
and only delays the inevitable debt
also hurts your credit score which can
greatly affect your ability to take on
necessary debt in the future
such as buying a house or car it also in
effect
takes away from your future income if
you are in debt with minimum payments of
100 pounds per month then that is 100
pounds you have to pay
or it simply increases the next time
possibly
even resulting in debt collectors
knocking on your door
or a date in court i know that sometimes
debt can't be avoided and i'm not trying
to berate those who get into
unmanageable debt i'm simply discussing
how it can
unfortunately ruin your life for all the
incredible good that capitalism does
debt is undeniably one of its ugliest
facets
compound debt is precisely what happens
to former billionaire
and liquor tycoon vijay malia aka
the king of good times he racked up
enormous bank debts and when i say
enormous
his company kingfisher airlines owed
1.35
billion us dollars in 2015.
his high-flying party lifestyle
certainly didn't help matters
vijay was left unable to pay his debtors
and the bank soon came after him
using a diplomatic passport he fled
india to the uk
but as of april of this year his appeal
against extradition failed
and he'll likely be brought home to face
justice and
further ruined to his reputation the
king of good times for others maybe
but not so much for himself alongside
dead many of us have
no savings which in easy times is fine
but in times of crisis such as now or
retirement
can become a serious problem that
greatly affects our life
almost one third of all u.s adults are
reported to have
no emergency savings and one survey even
found that 58
of americans have less than 1 000 in
savings
if you find yourself on the wrong end of
ill health you could find yourself
in desperate wants of money you never
knew you needed
so is there anything else in life that
can totally destroy your future
like debt can well yes try
poor social skills believe it or not but
the consequences can be just
as bad in simple terms poor social
skills don't allow you to foster
meaningful connections with others and
when this happens we experience
a painful sense of loneliness and when i
say painful
i mean quite literally loneliness isn't
just some
fleeting mildly annoying phenomenon it's
one of the most dangerous
persistent and damaging emotions to your
health and minds that you can possibly
experience
unlike when you're late for an
appointment and the stress leaves as
soon as you arrive
in the case of loneliness you're left
with a persistent
aching feeling that does not go away
unless you form a meaningful
reliable relationship and this can take
a lot of time this is why lonely people
often feel like they're searching for
something they need
but cannot find it and this searching
process is extremely painful
social skills are largely formed amongst
your family and
learnt over time but whilst they can be
learned few of us actually practice the
skills needed
skills such as opening up to others
emotionally supporting them
asserting oneself starting relationships
or introducing yourself to people you
meet in the world
we generally interact with others with
little regard to the skills we're
developing
this has been made a lot worse by the
fact that modern communication methods
such as instant messaging
don't produce the intimate
neurochemistry needed
to form lasting bonds teach social
skills
and heal loneliness which can only be
gotten
from face-to-face communication
the lifetime costs of this can be
immeasurable
for example loneliness is deeply linked
to stress
depression and anxiety which have
widespread effects on every aspect of
your life and
overall well-being likewise it is also
strongly connected to dementia
heart disease and overall mortality
with some writers and researchers
referring to loneliness itself
as an epidemic that must be treated
especially when loneliness traditionally
high in the elderly
has been growing in young adults and
teenagers
it's no wonder then in the uk alone
loneliness related conditions like
depression and anxiety
cost a country 77 billion pounds per
year
more abstractly while's loneliness may
have debilitating effects on your mental
and physical health
gradually degrading the quality of your
life poor social skills will also affect
your opportunities in life and your
career
asserting yourself and asking your boss
for a raise will be significantly more
difficult
and you won't have the widespread social
connections that gave birth to the
phrase
it's who you know not what you know
which
unfortunately is true more often than
not
just as damaging our poor relationship
choices
choosing your partner in life is one of
the most important choices you can make
but few of us understand just how
important that truly is
many studies have concluded that a bad
marriage is as damaging to your health
as heavy smoking or drinking
whilst huge sways of evidence suggests
that married couples
live longer and are happier so if it's
good
it's great if it's bad it's terrible
with a failed relationship there are
several costs the pain of the breakup is
obvious but in the case of marriage
well 50 of marriages in the u.s end in
divorce
and each comes with an average of 15 000
u.s
dollars in legal fees and because most
couples split their assets 50 50
psychologically you have to deal with
the blow of losing half your assets
for some couples this can be extremely
destructive both financially and
psychologically
the rate of suicide is 2.4 times higher
in divorced couples and divorced men are
nine times more likely to commit suicide
psychologists think that the biggest
cause of poor relationship choices
and bad social skills is a lack of
emotional
intelligence emotional intelligence is
essentially one's ability to recognize
his own emotions
and the emotions of others and
understand how to
interact with them in layman's terms
it's about having
empathy but whilst a lot of us sweat
about our iq how many of us are actually
concerned about our emotions
well you should be there are some
alarming costs that come from having
poor emotional intelligence to name a
few
you will tend to blame others more
become more argumentative
communicate poorly get easily and
needlessly offended
lose control over your emotions and have
outbursts
project your own flaws onto others and
fail to recognize
that you are doing so have no idea what
others are feeling and thus
unable to help them you'll probably call
them overly sensitive
you will easily get overwhelmed by
emotionally intense situations
you will likely damage your work
relationships personal relationships
and reduce your psychological well-being
and you are much
much more likely to be psychologically
destroyed
by trauma so all in all having poor
emotional intelligence
is fairly bad news but another way that
many of us ruin our lives is that we
fail to work on the things we want
to work on or even worse fail to develop
a work ethic of any kind
now don't worry you need to pull a mark
wahlberg and start waking up at 2am to
pray
and play 30 minutes of golf before you
hit the gym
but you definitely need to at least have
an average work ethic
failing to do so will leave you
chronically unproductive possibly
unemployable expose you to greater risk
of financial problems
and potentially even have you ostracized
by your friends due to your bad
influence all of which comes with the
costs i've already discussed
but the bar isn't that high really in a
nine to five
eight hour working day studies have
shown that people
on average only do work for free of them
so you only need to develop the habit of
being able to focus on the work you're
doing
for free hours not much and as authors
like daniel goldman have noted
focus itself is a muscle so the more you
work at it the better it gets
focus and self-control are so important
that one longitudinal study from new
zealand that followed one thousand
people
over five decades noted that young
children
self-control predicted their health
wealth and criminal history later in
life
no matter what their social background
or iq so start practicing that focus
but be warned it goes both ways the less
you practice it the worse it gets over
time
like a big life-destroying snowball
likewise many of us don't work on our
dreams we want to be an author a
filmmaker an inventor
or better yet a handsome mustachioed
youtuber
but we think we can't do it or worse
think we can
but continually wake up feeling like we
don't want to that day and tell
ourselves we'll
do it tomorrow but you know the drill
that tomorrow never comes
i've got news for you not many
successful people actually enjoy
the work they do on a daily basis
they may claim they do publicly but the
truth is they enjoy
achieving their goals but not the menial
daily slog
consider this quote i hated every minute
of training but i said
don't quit suffer now and you'll live
the rest of your life as a champion
well if even muhammad ali hated what he
did
why would your process be any easier
this is one of the secrets to getting
things done
you're always going to have to do
something that sucks
you are always going to have to do
something you don't want to
do so choose the thing that sucks the
least
after all if you don't push yourself and
you simply sail through life
have you actually lived as mark twain
said
20 years from now you will be more
disappointed by the things you didn't do
than the ones you did do so throw off
the bowl lines
sail away from safe harbor now
there's one method of ruining your life
that is perhaps
more effective than all of the others
combined and it is the same one that
tore
dicky eckland's life apart addiction
addiction is one of the most dangerous
conditions you can deal with in life
and will certainly rob you with your
money your mental and physical health
friendships relationships change your
personality for the worse
land you in prison or kill you and it's
far easier to suffer from than you'd
actually think
addiction comes in a variety of forms
sure drugs and alcohol are the obvious
but there are countless others such as
sex gambling and even video games and
internet use
which can all be equally as bad unless
of course
it's an addiction to my videos one of
the reasons addictions are so powerful
is that
generally they all operate under the
same principle
they hijack your brain's dopamine reward
system which controls your motivation
and reward centers
and focuses all your brain's energy on
whatever that addiction is
smoke more crack drink more booze play
more call of duty
this creates a vicious cycle where one
continually engages with his addiction
despite the negative costs to his own
life it doesn't matter if we don't do
the work we need to
we stress our partner out or blow all of
our money
eventually it's hard to think about
anything else other than how and when
you're going to get
high again but whilst the drugs
themselves come with literally
hundreds of life-destroying symptoms
there are a couple of symptoms that come
with any addiction
the first is withdrawal because of how
effectively addiction
hijacks your dopamine reward system when
you take away your source of addiction
i.e going cold turkey you will begin to
experience withdrawal
for example people who quit certain
drugs can have terrible seizures
and migraines but even people go in cold
turkey
on their video game addictions can feel
terrible feelings of emptiness
and sadness depression and desperate
attempts to rationalize
returning to gaming this means that
unlike other issues in this video
addiction is extremely hard to curb
once it has its claws into you
everything in you
will want you not to quit another
symptom is the cost it has to
relationships
as addiction takes over more and more of
your life it has a trying
cost on your relationships building the
lack of intimacy
trust and distance between you and your
close friends and partner
when they start voicing their concerns
about your habits you will often resort
to lying
to get them off your back or worse
violence
and whilst you're probably thinking look
that's fine and all but i don't have an
addiction
perhaps you need to take a closer look
addiction doesn't start with some
dramatic movie-like choice where
something traumatic happens and you
suddenly down an entire bottle of jack
daniels with your cornflakes
an addiction's origin is usually more
camouflaged and much more insidious
most addictions begin by accident you
try something once
like everyone does thinking what could
go wrong but whatever sadness emptiness
or pain
you had thought was normal to live with
suddenly
goes away as soon as you take your drug
gamble or play your game
things just seem to feel different and
better when you're using or doing it
life seems better until of course
you stop and from there it's a very very
slippery slope to wanting more and more
with devastating consequences but look i
don't want to end on a down note
to bring it back to our story at the
very beginning former boxer
dickie eklund was in a bad place he'd
destroyed his life
through alcohol landed himself in prison
and even had his entire failure
broadcasted the world over hbo
but his story didn't end there eklund
strived to get
clean faced his withdrawal head-on and
began to regain some control over his
life
eventually succeeding eklund was
released from prison
and helped to coach his half-brother and
former boxer mickey ward
on his comeback trail he coached his
brother for 26
fights including what became ward's
legendary trilogy
against arturo gatti all three of which
were awarded
fight of the year and will go down in
history as some of the greatest boxing
bouts of all time
and although he has struggled with
addiction since he has taken the steps
towards regaining control of his life
showing us all that the important fights
we win
aren't the ones in the ring but the ones
we face
against ourselves thank you for watching
if you enjoyed this video then please
consider supporting me on patreon
because
it really helps me to continue to make
these videos the links in the
description
also you can get your hands on a first
edition signed copy of my new book
stick if liking it by heading on over to
unbanned publishing
and pledging today the links in the
description thank you